série qu'est ce que l'intelligence
artificielle
ok voici ce que j'ai trouvé lit
l'article
voici le résultat de mes recherches sur
le web pour les articles série est très
intelligente
un sage a dit un jour qu'est-ce que je
suis doué 10 11 ans avec senti qu un
accent aigu c'est incroyable quand même
un avoir une conversation avec son
téléphone pour à travers son téléphone
avec son téléphone bon d'accord c'est
pas tout à fait au point
c'est pas comme dans star trek syrie
faisait pas de jarvis sur l'ordinateur
d'iron man mais quand même
saviez vous que 40 % des adolescents
américains converser régulièrement comme
ça avec leur téléphone à mais faut
réaliser que pour avoir cette
conversation il faut que machine est
entendu ce que j'ai dit qu'elle ait
donné un sens à ma question qu'elle ait
trouvé une réponse et qu'elle me réponde
qu'elle fasse une phrase un bon français
si vie pour pouvoir faire ça doit être
une machine qui apprend mais après c'est
pas évident de se faire une image
mentale de ce que ça peut représenter
pour une machine nous par exemple on a
appris à parler et à marcher à lire à
écrire à faire de la bicyclette
ça nous a pris quoi 6,7 en jeu pendant
ce temps là il y avait plein neurones
des collections qui se faisait dans
notre cerveau mais siri ça lui a pris
comble n combien de temps apprendre à
parler pour apprendre une machine a
besoin de donner des mégatonnes de
données du big data et puis des
mathématiques les mathématiques assez
compliqué merci on commence à prendre
ces données-là qui on les fait penser
parce qu'on appelle des algorithmes des
algorithmes et des mathématiques qui
nous servent à ranger classer donner un
sens aux données puis ensuite avec ses
algorithmes reproduire ce qu'on appelle
un modèle prédictif
ce sont des équations qui vont décret
ce que la machine a appris avec les
données qu'on lieu donné ça s'appelle
l'apprentissage machine
c'est ça aussi comme ça que siri elle a
appris à parler
cette capacité technologique cette
capacité de donner un sens à des
mégatonnes d'information qui provient
d'un peuple qui proviennent d'un peu
partout ça s'appelle le big data et ça
va nous permettre de faire des choses
absolument extraordinaire qu'on a vu
quelques exemples aujourd'hui imaginer
ça dans quelques temps on vous révèle
dix minutes plus tôt que d'habitude
parce que votre maison s'est rendu
compte qu'il y avait une tempête de
neige et considère que ça va prendre un
peu plus que dix minutes pour faire ce
que vous avez à faire ce matin elle a
aussi augmenter la température de la
salle de bains dix minutes plus tôt que
prévu vous allez déjeuner vous manger
des céréales avec du lait qui a été
livré la veille par un drone parce que
votre frigo s'est rendu compte que vous
en aviez pu à lorient ne commande et
vous prenez votre téléphone puis vous
regardez à quelques coins de rue vous
devriez aller pour prendre le moyen de
transport le plus rapide et le moins
coûteux ou si vous êtes chanceux vous
embarquer dans la voiture électrique
autonome familiale et d'un an vont à
l'université
on va dire que vous étudié en ingénierie
et vous faites votre projet de fin
d'études avec une étude avec une équipe
d'étudiants chinois en chine mais en
téléprésence par par skype par exemple
sauf que les étudiants chinois parlent
ni français ni anglais et puis vous vous
parlez pas mandarin c'est pas grave
lorsqu'il ya un système de traduction
simultanée intégré au logiciel de
téléprésence et ça on est tout près de
ça tout ça grâce à notre capacité de
générer gérer et analyser des mégots
tonnes de données
mais c'est quoi une donnée une donnée
c'est l'information que vous retrouvez
sur le web c'est la météo c'est
l'actualité c'est des textes des images
cd vidéo c'est des données qui sont
envoyées par des objets connectés par
les compteurs intelligents
d'hydro-québec par votre téléphone qui
donne votre localisation par un gps dans
un camion de livraison
ça peut aussi des données qui ont été
prises par des sondages de façon
traditionnelle
un commun avec statistique canada et
puis au bout vous générer des données
vos jeux facebook
instagram snatch à twitter à ce point
femme vous générer des quantités
phénoménales de données on dit que
depuis 2003 on génère deux ans génère en
deux jours plus de données que ce qu'on
a généré depuis le début de l'humanité
et 70% de ces données là proviennent des
individus de vous de moi de lui
2 l de lui là bas pour vous donner une
idée de ce que ça représente là il ya
146 milliards de tweets qui sont
partagés chaque année sur facebook il ya
350 giga octets qui sont partagés chaque
minute ayant eu à 4100 statut qui sont
partagées à la seconde 4100 statut 4100
statut 4100 statut et en 2014
il ya 30 milliards de photos qui ont été
partagés sur instagram 30 milliards
absolument phénoménale on dit que le
prochain pétrole est basse et les
données que notre économie ça va être
une économie numérique une économie du
savoir ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que au lieu d'exploiter des ressources
physiques comme l'eau le bois le fer le
pétrole et bien on va exploiter des
données
au lieu d'acheter des objets physiques
on va acheter des services par exemple
au lieu d'acheter un journal on veut
s'abonner à un système d'information au
lieu d'acheter un film sur blu ray eh
bien on va le regarder en streaming
ça s'appelle la dématérialisation et ce
qui est chouette avec la
dématérialisation c'est que ça va nous
permettre de réduire notre impact sur
l'environnement en produisant et en
consommant moins de biens physiques et
surtout en général en générant moins de
déchets et sa sis à condition ne pas
changer de téléphone à tous les six mois
il ya quelque chose d'assez intéressant
qui est en train de se passer avec cette
nouvelle façon de penser ces nouvelles
possibilités
ça c'est quelque chose que beaucoup
circulé sur les réseaux sociaux pour
nous faire réaliser que hubert dont on
entend beaucoup parler la plus grande
compagnie de taxis ne possède aucun
véhicule facebook la plus grande
entreprise médiatique ne produit aucun
contenu alibaba le plus grand magasin du
monde n'a pas d'inventaire et airbnb le
plus grand fournisseur d'hébergement ne
possède aucun hôtel la dématérialisation
ça va avoir aussi d'autres impacts sur
notre vie avant quand on regardait un
mot dans le dictionnaire les personnes
qui voyaient ce qu'on regardait il n'y
avait pas d' historique des mots qu'on
avait cherché dans dictionnaire quand on
prenait une photo ou une personne qui
voyait ce qu'on avait pris en photo se
retenant le téléphone dans dans le dans
le téléphone dans l'appareil photo
avant quand on écrivait au rendez vous
dans notre agenda une personne qui
savait ce qu'on avait écrit maintenant
avec la dématérialisation toute cette
information là est connecté tout est
connecté à quelque chose il ya des
entreprises comme apport des gogos qui
font beaucoup de sous avec les traces
qu'on laisse serein sur internet car
tout laisse des traces soucier des
principes du web
vous avez peut-être déjà entendu la
phrase si c'est gratuit c'est que c'est
vous le produit on va regarder vos
traces qu'il faudrait que vous laissez
sur internet pour mieux vous comprendre
et mieux vous vendre des choses par
exemple dans le monde du jeu vidéo
il ya ce qu'on appelle des game
analystes qui vont capter tout ce que
vous faites lorsque vous jouez en ligne
pour comprendre votre comportement être
en mesure de vous offrir les thèmes que
vous êtes le plus susceptibles d'acheter
dans le feu de l'action
par exemple l'épée de feu qui va vaincre
le troll à 3 ou que vous êtes juste pro
capable de battre 99 sièges pas cher il
ya aussi des boutiques virtuelles vous
pouvez essayer des vêtements
virtuellement
et puis si vous aimez ça mais vous
pouvez vous prendre en photo puis vous
pouvez vous l'envoyer dans votre
téléphone et ça y est ils ont votre
numéro de téléphone et l'historique de
ce que vous avez essayé quand vous allez
vous promener près d'un magasin qui vend
des vêtements que vous avez essayé mais
votre téléphone vibre et vous informer
que vous avez 5 % de rabais sur les
pantalon bleu que vous avez essayé vous
êtes le produit mais bon si la vie hein
parce que si on veut pouvoir profiter de
ce genre de service faut que quelqu'un
paye en bout de ligne faut simplement en
être conscient et partager votre
information personnelle de façon
responsable et ça ça fait peur à bien
des gens y en a beaucoup qui ont peur du
big data et de l'intelligence
artificielle parce qu'ils se disent
qu'on va mieux nous comprendre pour
mieux nous manipuler être la capacité
d'exploiter ses mégots tonnes de données
est vraiment phénoménal ça peut rendre
un monde meilleur mais ça peut aussi
nous rendent idiot dépendants et
vulnérable parce que comme l'oncle ben
and peter parker mieux connu sous le nom
de spider man l'a si bien dit avec un
grand pouvoir viennent de grandes
responsabilités
alors où allez-vous nous amener vers un
monde meilleur où vers un monde
vulnérable et dépendants parce que
l'avenir vous appartient
dans cette nouvelle ère de la méga
données du big data
ça va être important de développer son
sens critique dans cet océan de données
mais ça va être important de faire mieux
que les machines et développer et
décupler votre intelligence
merci